hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a vlog I know I know
pretty goddamn terrible and don't worry
this isn't gonna be the only video today
but I realized that with my new schedule
I don't often have an opportunity to
just talk to you guys and I I miss out
on that I mean I want to do more live
streams and stuff like that too
in addition to this new schedule like
I've been really happy with it but also
it's it's freed up a lot of time to not
only pursue things that I want to do in
terms of music and other hobbies that I
have but it also frees up some time to
do more live streams but that's not the
point of this video the main point of
this video is because I wanted to talk
to you guys about packs and the
markiplier calendar number one we
actually raised a lot more money than we
thought we did at the end of the
campaign the website said that we raised
about three hundred and eighty two
thousand three hundred and eighty-five
dollars the actual amount raised is a
lot higher than that because with more
calendars sold the production costs go
down and that means more money is able
to go for charity I'm being told I
haven't gotten a clear number yet
because they still have to ship it to me
so that I can hand signed every one of
those but they have to ship it to me and
then I have to ship it back and then
they have to ship it out to everybody
and that's just more cost for shipping
but it shouldn't be too much more but
what I'm being told is that the actual
number is around half a million dollars
raised for the Cancer Research Institute
and I wanted to tell you guys that
because I'm incredibly proud of that
number like that's an astonishingly huge
number for charity it's so big in fact
it is a new record that's something that
you should be incredibly proud about
that is a new record and that
comes just after we did one in November
where with the help of someone else with
an anomalous donor for Save the Children
we raised over four hundred thousand
dollars for charity but this is all you
guys this is all you guys buying this
tasteful nudes calendar to see my butt
plastered across a few months and we
raised almost half a million dollars for
charity that's incredible
so I just wanted to say thank you you
know thank you guys so much for
supporting this weird
way of doing charity for celebrating 20
million subscribers and also accepting
this new weird way that I want to do
videos and in all honesty it's not that
weird it's just one longer or more dense
video a day and it's been a lot of fun
you know I've been very happy with
creating things just the past few weeks
that I've had and admittedly I've been
doing mostly gaming stuff because with
the 20 million subscriber calendar and
with going to pax I haven't had time to
make a lot of live-action goofs but I've
got tons of ideas that I want to
implement some of them involve a
paintball gun and I have to go get a
paintball gun and then I think Tyler's
gonna have to shoot me with it you're
gonna see it's not just me punishing
myself for the sake of being punishment
I've got an idea for it don't worry
about it anyway it's it's just been it's
it's a lot of fun it's been a lot of fun
I've been really happy about it
I'm just excited for the future and we
just came back from pax and I was able
to hang out with my friends again I was
able to see people that I haven't seen
in a long time and we were able to talk
about the future we were able to talk
about things that weren't just video
making it and you know I you know I'm
just really happy I I think that's shown
in the videos that I've been making but
I think you guys can see it and I've
just been really happy and now that I'm
back and the only thing I have to look
forward to in the next trip is Wade's
wedding which it's just a crazy thing to
even think about
congratulations wait he's gonna get
married in May but it's you know it's
yeah there's a lot of things to look
forward to this year and there's a lot
of things that I've been able to look
forward to and yeah it's been good
anyone that's all I wanted to say I've
got another quick video that I'm gonna
be putting out today something that I've
been addicted to fortnight and I've been
playing it on my own a lot I mean pretty
much everybody in the world is addicted
to fortnight now and I've never been one
to play it a lot but I've been playing
it on my own and I haven't been
streaming it just because like I'm not
good enough or - I'm not good enough I
don't think I'm good enough to compete I
was playing with Tyler yesterday we were
just blowing each other up in high
explosive mode and laughing our asses
off and you know it's been fun anyway
I'll stop rambling I'll get out of here
quick I just wanted to make a quick
update
video for you guys and just thanks
thanks for being there with me you know
for me you know thanks for being here
with me you know thanks for sticking by
me and thanks for believing those are
the most important things that I could
ever ask for it you guys have delivered
in more ways than I ever could have
imagined so thanks anyway I'll let you
go take care of yourselves thank you
everybody so much for watching as always
in the next video bye bye